you don't have to be happy all the time
you can try to create your life so that
you're doing things that make you happy
and give you the best chance of being
happy every day but you don't have to be
happy all the time hi I'm Evan
Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and the other
day I posted on my twitter account that
I was frustrated and I was going to go
eat some marshmallows and some people
wrote back to me saying that they were
surprised that I got frustrated thinking
that I had everything figured out I'm
just a guy I'm just a normal person like
you of course they get frustrated of
course I get angry of course I get sad
I've tried to design my life in a way
that I'm doing the things that I love
doing to maximize my chance of being
happy every day I'm following my passion
with my business I try to spend time
doing the hobbies that I love I try to
spend time with the people that I love
and that gives me the best chance of
being happy as much as possible but life
still throws you curveballs there are
days when you are not going to be happy
where you're going to get frustrated or
sad or angry and that's okay there's
nothing wrong with it you don't have to
pretend like you're happy all the time
because if you do you're cheating
yourself out of an opportunity to really
connect with people it's great to share
your wins and share the highs but will
you really form lasting deep meaningful
connections with people is usually
around the sad times in our lives we are
upset or where you're angry or you're
really sad you can use that as a chance
to really connect with people so you
don't have to be happy all the time
don't pretend like you are it's okay and
tomorrow will be a better day
for those of you watching if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes want to do more for you
and I'd love to hear you have to think
about this video or if you have a
question for your business feel free to
leave it in the comments below I always
read those I really love see them come
in and i'll see you on the next episode
you